if you follow my writing at the
federalist or subscribe to my newsletter
the transom you know i have a collection
of things
i truly hate that list includes man buns
kale
the eagles both musical and sports the
films of brit marling and above all the
commission on presidential debates
the commission is an antique it does not
serve the interests of the american
people
you have seen it time and again deployed
biased moderators who seek only to
undermine the republican candidate
and give the democrat every opportunity
to win it's the most obviously biased
game
since tim donny through the 2002 western
conference finals to the lakers over the
kings
it's a joke we all know it since the
moment cnn's candy crowley acted as a
second debater against mitt romney in
2012
republicans should have moved on from
the commission
it took the president 14 days before he
called the attack in benghazi
an act of terror get the transcript he
did in fact sir so let me let me
call it an actor
he did call it an act of terror it did
as well take it did as well uh
take two weeks or so uh for the whole
idea of there being a riot out there
about this tape
to come out you're correct
the commission is a feeble-aged remnant
of a time when there were just three
channels on tv
even bob dole thinks it has outlived its
usefulness
and this time around they set up a
debate with a c-span anchor
who was openly asking anthony scaramucci
for debate questions to knife president
trump
and then lied about it claiming he was
hacked he should know that only joy reid
can get away with lies like that
for years now i've been calling for the
gop to ditch the tired old debate format
and run these things differently this
long past time
we got rid of format restrictions and
anchors with obvious bias
i would rather watch a debate moderated
by tucker carlson and rachel maddow
or laura ingram and van jones then
submit to the likes of the aggressively
hackish john harwood
whose opening question in cnbc's 2016
debate
was this mr trump yes
you've done very well in this campaign
so far by
promising to build a wall and make
another country pay for it right
send 11 million people out of the
country
cut taxes 10 trillion dollars without
increasing the deficit
right and make americans better off
because your greatness would replace the
stupidity and incompetence of others
that's right
let's be honest is this a comic book
version of a presidential campaign
what a deep question today the rnc
finally announced they would be
breaking with the commission finally
chairperson
ronna mcdaniel said after repeated
missteps and partisan actions that
underscored its biases last cycle
it's clear that the commission on
presidential debates is no longer
providing the fair and impartial forum
for presidential debates which the law
requires and the american people deserve
last year i heartily endorse the idea
that joe rogan should moderate a
presidential debate
and why not he's the best interviewer
working today and i predicted
this is the last year in which the
commission on presidential debates
will be determinative about these things
people are tired of this format
they're ready to move on to something
for the age of youtube and they're not
going to have a bunch of people born in
the 30s and 40s
dictate parameters and name their
favorite tv host to do this in 2024.
joe rogan may not get to moderate a
debate this time but eventually
he will that's a good thing it means we
might actually get some answers
that matter joining me now molly
hemingway senior editor for the
federalist and a fox news contributor
thank you for joining me molly
great to be here with you why did it
take the rnc so long to do this thing
that we all as viewers have viewed as an
obvious problem for a long time
it's amazing that it took so long you
know the trump campaign the year before
the election actually said that they
were thinking about not working with the
presidential debate commission
but then they did and it was a huge and
catastrophic error for them
you know the democratic party had a
strategy for 2020 it was to keep
joe biden kind of hidden and to do
massive amounts of mail-in early
balloting
and the debate commission once that once
that started happening you know that
there were all these early votes and
mail-in balloting
the trump campaign said well shouldn't
we move the debates up since people are
already going to be voting
and the debate commission steadfastly
refused knowing that it would hurt the
democratic strategy of how to elect
joe biden so you had the first debate
happening nearly a month
after people began voting and then you
have the issues that you were talking
about with moderators who clearly were
you know favorable toward biden they had
to drop the second debate because of the
problems with the
the moderator who claimed he got hacked
and they didn't they were embarrassed
about it
there were so many problems including
that they said they were going to do a
foreign policy debate which of course
was president trump's strong point
and a strong point that a lot of
republicans hadn't had in a long time
and because it was a strong point they
dropped that it was they dropped it they
no longer did a foreign policy debate i
mean this is just
a high level of meddling in an election
that is inappropriate
for a group that is supposedly
bipartisan as you know this was a
situation where you know uniquely
because of
the restrictions of the pandemic the
debates mattered
so much more this was like the only time
you were going to get any real
interaction from joe biden or have him
answer
any of the critical questions that seem
rather relevant now especially as it
relates to
our relationship with china iran israel
and the like
why did we have such a complete media
shutdown why weren't they clamoring
for the debate commission to push these
things up so that we could actually have
these questions answered
right because the media also were on the
same side as the democratic party and
the debate commission and so it was all
working in
everybody's favor but the people who
lost out were the american people
and you know this is something that's
been a problem like you said for so long
we need to have really good debates
where you can kind of dig deep and see
what people's different
positions are not just what they're
going to answer in a very short period
of time
and so i hope that when i'm so glad this
era is over it needed to die a long time
ago
but i hope going forward we get some
really good discussions you know
between the candidates and also maybe
not just the two main party candidates
but other parties that you know that
that might need an
airing as well so there's a lot that can
happen in the days it's it's absolutely
crazy to me because i
i know you love debates the same way
that i do we're junkies we
we love them going back you know there's
so many critical moments that have been
determinative in
uh in american politics that come from
them and yet
this seems to be something that the the
major parties and those involved
really haven't been able to get right
for a long time what
is one change that you would like to
make to
the debate format or to the way that
moderators are chosen
that would lead to having some good
outcomes and better questions and
answers
i would actually like no moderators i
would like to see
each candidate ask the other candidate a
question and see you know see what kind
of questions they're asking or what are
the issues that are of importance
and have a real conversation moderators
have not worked for a long time now and
so go ahead and let them go
but let's go ahead and have the
candidates have some real debate
i i certainly am in favor of that i
think as a
as a substitute instead of a debate we
could also have the candidates just
manage a dairy queen for a week
and see who came out on top at the end
of the week because that to me would
actually be more reflective
of the job of having to run something
than this
current back and forth which has been so
artificial molly thank you so much for
joining me tonight
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis
you will not get it anywhere else